elle était la fille de mes rêves c'était
le moment où j'ai su que c'était fait nous nous sommes
rencontrés il y a trois ans tu es une ligue
à part entière Gauri
excellent quelle est ta boisson préférée du
jus de pamplemousse avec de la vodka et trois
cerises au marasquin hé tu veux avoir
hors d'ici ouais c'était le
premier rendez-vous parfait mais j'ai attendu trop longtemps et
puis j'ai eu la mort oh c'est tellement agréable d'
avoir un bon ami que je ne peux même pas
vous dire avec un arbre seulement je pouvais revenir en arrière et le
faire avec  vous différemment je pourrais être
le gars que vous voudrez peut-être pourriez-vous
me dire quelle année nous sommes c'est 2014 je viens de
voyager dans le temps en
ce moment j'ai quelqu'un à rencontrer quelle est
votre boisson préférée la
mienne est du jus de pamplemousse avec de la vodka et
exactement trois cerises au marasquin c'est
mon jus de boisson préféré c'est quoi le
psychopathe dont je te parlais tu
n'as pas deviné que j'étais un gamin de l'armée tu
savais déjà que tu es un harceleur du
football ou nous sommes comme des trenchs et
pas de sous-vêtements et je porte clairement
look de sous-vêtements e  le photomaton est une
machine à remonter le temps ça va être la meilleure nuit
de ta vie
je peux gérer la meilleure nuit de ma vie
suis ce que je fais
prêt What's Up Girl What's Up Girl
ha tu fais l'imitation du Joker
c'est non c'est comme  c'était bien tout le
reste échoue être un connard être un connard
pas connard dur connard doux n'oublie pas
ton euh pantalon en cuir oh mon dieu
j'ai été connard complet
trois ans plus tard avec les conséquences,
je pensais que les choses devaient arriver
pour une raison, les choses arrivent sans raison
du tout, mais elles créent des opportunités, la
question est de savoir si vous pouvez reconnaître cette prochaine
opportunité quand ça compte le plus
[Musique]
oh regarde j'ai compris  c'est bon, je suis
désolé que ça ait gâché ta
soirée magique pour avoir une belle vie
[Musique]
toi